A computer game is like any
other creative endeavor,
it takes a lot of effort and it's hard
to know exactly when you're finished.
You may have heard of the 80/20 rule for
software development,
that 80% of the effort goes to
completing the last 20% of the features.
That's true for games too, to an extent,
but there's another factor.
Good games have more than just lots of
features, they also need good gameplay.
While Future Creep blows a lot of
development schedules, with games,
it's less a matter of
adding features and
more about making sure the features
are tuned so the game is actually fun.
In a way, it's like painting or writing.
You're always tempted to
tweak some character stat or
rearrange those two sentences.
Does this change make things clearer?
Do I need to rethink how
I present this piece?
Games aren't like other software.
They're not necessarily function driven,
right?
They're meant to entertain and
engage and
these are fundamentally
subjective goals.
So, you may find yourself near the end
of a game project, making less and
less progress towards the finish line.
Don't be surprised and
don't let it discourage you.
You're doing what every creative
person on the planet does,
which is second guess yourself and
tweak and edit and revisit and change.
And just like those creative people,
you're going to eventually decide you're
satisfied with the final product.
And after all that work,
there's nothing quite like the feeling
of actually releasing your game.